[Music]
today i'm going to talk about how to
make shiny apps faster with caching
using features from the new version of
shiny version 1.6
here's an app that shows average weather
patterns over the course of a year
so let's take a look at the weather
where i live in minneapolis
we'll load the data and the weather here
is pretty typical for the continental
united states it's
hot in the summer cold in the winter
and it rains more in the summer and
less in the winter i have relatives that
live in the bay area in california and
sometimes i compare my weather to theirs
and i feel a little sad
but then i compare real estate prices
and i feel a lot better
so here's the weather for redwood city
california
and in the summers it's uh it's warm in
the winters it's cooler but it doesn't
ever get really cold and in the winters
it rains a lot and in the summers it
rains almost not at all
now with this app there's a button that
you can use to switch between the
previous city and the current one
so you can switch to minneapolis by
clicking on there
and back to redwood city by clicking on
it again
but you notice that every time we do
that it has to re-go out and re-fetch
the data and then redraw the plots and
that takes
time and so this experience of switching
back and forth
isn't really a great one now how can we
make it better
well the answer is with caching
here's some simplified code from the app
we have the weather data which is a
reactive expression
and that calls a function called fetch
data and you give that the city
that you want to fetch the data for that
goes out to the internet it grabs the
data
and then it returns this takes a while
this is the this is the slowest part of
the application
in shiny 1.6 we've added a function
called
bind cache the way it works is you
pass your reactive expression to the
bind cache function
and then you tell it what to use as the
cache key in this case it's
input dollar city so the first time you
have a particular value of input dollar
city
it will run the reactive expression and
store the value in the cache
and then if you ever have that same
value again
instead of having to recompute the
reactive expression it can just
fetch the old value out of the cache
and in this case that means we don't we
don't have to go to the internet to
fetch the data
the other part of our app that takes
significant time is the plot rendering
with render plot
and as it turns out you can use bind
cache with a render plot as well
so that the plots for a particular city
instead of having to be recomputed every
time
they can be simply fetched from the
cache and this can really speed things
up
okay let's look at our app again but
this time with caching so all we did was
add
bind cache to reactive expression and to
the render plots
and that's it now when we look at these
cities and switch back and forth between
them
it's pretty much instantaneous because
instead of having to fetch the data and
recompute the plots it just
grabs the plots and the data right out
of the cache which is very very
fast so we've seen bind cast used with
reactive and with render plot and i
should mention that
before shiny 1.6 it was possible to use
caching
with plots by using the render cached
plot function
but that's now equivalent to using
render plot and bind cache
but it doesn't stop there you can also
use bind cache with
other render functions like render text
and it will even work with render
functions that are not in shiny
itself like render plotly from the
plotly package
all you have to do is add bind cached to
the end of it
if you've written one of these render
functions in most cases it will just
work with bind cache but if not
typically the changes that you need to
make are quite small just a few lines of
code
there are a few details you might be
wondering about so
first is the size of the cache the
default size is 200 megabytes
in memory now that size can be changed
and
instead of using it memory the cache can
also be stored on disk
next the scope the cache is shared
across
all user sessions of an application by
default
and that means that if one person
fetches a particular data set or views a
particular plot
then other users can benefit from that
but if that's a problem for your
particular
use case then the cache can be scoped to
just one session instead
next the lifetime a memory cache is
discarded when the app
exits or it restarts but a disk based
cache
can persist across app restarts and can
even be shared across multiple
simultaneous
r processes serving up the same app as
you might do with
connect or shiny server pro thanks for
listening and
i hope that you find bind cash useful
for speeding up and scaling up your
shiny applications
you